The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, I think
we'll make a start
since it's almost 10 past.
Can everyone hear
me in Singapore?
Wave if you can.
No?
Oh, yes you can.
Excellent.
Right, I think that there's
a couple of announcements
before we start.
I'm going to have office hours
tomorrow between 5:00 and 6:00
in case you have any questions
about the current problem
set, which is due on
Thursday at 5:00 PM MIT time.
And we are marking the
quizzes as fast as we can,
so you'll have them back soon.
If you have any comments
about the quiz, how
you found the
questions and so forth,
then I'd be delighted
to hear them.
Any questions?
OK.
Singapore?
No.
So anyway, today I'm going
to introduce a tool that's
going to be very helpful to
us as we look to have ways
of studying a process
and understanding exactly
how its inputs relate to its
outputs, so that by doing that,
we can eventually model the
process, control it better,
and improve its performance.
And that technique is called the
analysis of variance, or ANOVA.
I want first to quickly
review the tools
that we've looked at in the
course so far so that we
can put ANOVA into perspective.
And we talked for the
first couple of lectures
about a systems view of
manufacturing processes.
We talked about a variety of
parameters that were important
in determining the outputs, some
of which we have control over,
some of which we don't-- some of
which are actually disturbances
or inherent properties of the
equipment or the material that
we're processing.
And so we have this
idea that there
must be some relationship
between the inputs and outputs.
But we've actually focused
on developing tools that
just focus on the
output-- on interpreting
the output, the geometry,
some other property.
And that's fine.
That's an important tool.
And here are some
of the tools we've
looked at for statistical
testing purposes.
There are, of course,
the T and the F tests.
And we looked at control
charts, which are essentially
running hypothesis tests
that a processes in control.
We're testing the
hypothesis that the process
mean, or variation,
is of a certain value.
We looked at
cumulative some charts,
and we looked at
moving average charts.
Then briefly, two
lectures ago, we
looked at Chi-squared
and T-squared charts.
So let's look at the
properties of those things just
to remind ourselves.
The key thing with
the hypothesis tests
and with the control charts
is that what we're doing
is we're interpreting changes in
one particular specific output
variable.
So whether that be diameter,
or threshold voltage,
or something, all
these hypothesis tests
are comparing sample mean,
sample variances based
on one output variable.
And with the Chi-squared and
the T-squared squared charts,
we introduced the ability
to look at two outputs
which might have
different dimensions,
and which we expect to be
somehow interdependent.
So we're allowing
ourselves to interpret
two different outputs.
Thinking about the
number of samples
that you can interpret with
any one of these given tests,
well, with a T or an F test,
you're taking two samples
and you're comparing them.
So in the case of a T test,
you're asking the question,
is there evidence that there's
a significant difference
between the means
of the underlying
distributions of the two
samples you've taken?
And with the F
test, we're saying,
is there a
significant difference
between the underlying
variances of two distributions?
With a control
chart, well that's
just a running hypothesis test.
So you take many samples,
and you're constantly
doing a hypothesis test to
see whether the process is
at the place where
you want it to be,
so some predetermined
operating point
that your content is
optimal, I suppose
And with the Chi-squared
and the T-squared charts,
again, the same is
true-- many samples.
But when we come to ask,
well, how many inputs
were we dealing
with these things,
we don't necessarily
have any idea.
We might be told that some input
to the process was changed,
here are some samples, is there
evidence that the input has
had an effect on the output?
But sometimes, we
might just have samples
and have no clear
understanding of what
the relevant inputs were.
So there's nothing
inherent in these tools
that allows us to get the
relationship between inputs
and outputs.
And similarly, we
don't know how many
levels or different values
any given input to a process
might take-- how many voltages
we set a particular control
voltage to.
And so I've said
that they're unknown.
But in a sense, I put
two with a question mark.
Because you might think, in a
very clearly defined T test,
say, you might say, well, an
operator varies one input.
And here are some samples.
Did the output change?
So in that case, you'd
have two samples--
two values for a
particular input.
And that might be the most
sort of precisely defined type
of test you can do.
We've also talked about
yield modeling, where
we're starting to try to
get some physical concept
of the link between
properties of the process--
the actual nature of
the process-- and what
comes out at the other
end in terms of yield;
and process
capability, where we're
trying to ask questions about
how well the process performs
based on being centered at
a particular output mean.
But those tools, again,
don't necessarily
let us model the
process, or indeed
give us any insight with
which to improve it.
So we need we need
some tools that
will start letting us
do that, especially
if we look at some typical data.
Now you'll recall,
this set of data,
this was used in
problem set two.
This is from an
injection molding
experiment done at
MIT for the course
of a couple of years ago.
And so what we've got here is
an output, which is diameter.
We've got one output
that we've measured,
but we've got two
input parameters
that we think are relevant.
There may be others.
And in fact, there
almost certain they are.
Because when we look at--
when we look at
the sample of parts
with a given combination
of these input parameters,
velocity and hold
time, we see that there
is substantial variation.
And that is either due to
inherent random variation
in properties of the materials,
or some input variable
that we haven't
fully controlled.
But we've got two input certain
parameters, and two values
that we happen to have
chosen for each of them.
Now, we could start to look
for significant differences
between the means
for each setting
by doing a whole raft
of T tests or F tests.
But you know, that would
become tedious quite quickly,
especially if you're
starting to look
at many variables
in many settings.
So we need a more systematic
way of going about this,
and eventually being able
to say which of the inputs
is important in determining
the value of the output.
Eventually, once we
have those tools,
well, there are a few
aims that we might have.
And first among those is
developing a process model.
So we want to be able to relate
inputs and disturbances--
so inputs that we
can't control--
to the outputs.
And we want to know which
inputs are relevant-- which
inputs, when they vary
by a reasonable amount,
actually have a significant
effect on the outputs
that we're interested
in understanding.
Once we've done
that, we can think
about optimizing the process.
A target that we might
have is to maximize CPK,
minimize the cost
associated with deviation
from our target output value.
We might have
particular models that
allow us to look at the impact
of, say, a candidate process
change to the mean outputs, to
the variance of the outputs.
These are all saying
essentially the same thing,
that if we can model a process,
we can control it better.
If you had perfect understanding
of the physics surrounding
the process that you had,
you could work forward
from first principles.
And you could think about every
physical phenomenon going on
in your system and predict
what the output would be.
But we don't.
We don't have understanding
of all the variables
that are at play.
And what this means is that
to get control of a process,
we need to work backwards
from the physical output.
We need to take measurements
of what the process is doing,
and model backwards to
understand what the inputs do.
So when we're doing this
kind of empirical modeling,
there's some questions
we need to ask ourselves.
What are we trying to achieve?
Do we want to minimize
quality loss, maximize CPK?
Do we just want to
reduce the variance
for some specific reason?
We need to define our
system very carefully.
What is the output?
Are there multiple outputs?
Are there multiple inputs?
What do we want to vary?
What does it cost us at
least to vary, either
in exploring the process
space, or actually what
does it cost us least to
control in the factory?
And we need to come up
with some sort of model--
some sort of of form for
the model that we can use.
We haven't yet described
any particular model.
This function phi
we've been talking
about in previous
lectures hasn't
been specific to any
particular process.
What's also
important is to think
about how easy it is to
collect data from the process.
If you have 20
variables and they can--
each vary over a
factor of ten, one
needs to start thinking
about how one can simplify
the process of doing
these experiments
and working towards a
model, especially if there's
a lot of measurements
of the outputs involved,
a lot of laborious measurement.
So going back to that chart
of the tools we have so far,
what we're going to do
today is add a new one.
And that is the
analysis of variance.
Now, the key
advantage of this is
that we're now starting to
be specific about looking
at the actual inputs
that we're interested in
and how they impact the outputs.
And so we might just
be interested in--
we might just be interested
in studying one input.
But equally, there
are ANOVA techniques
that will let us study
multiple input parameters.
Is there a question
in Singapore?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
have a question.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: What is a
Chi-squared chart,
and why does it
have two outputs?
PROFESSOR: Right,
well this I think
we covered in lecture
two-- two lectures ago,
certainly the T-squared chart.
What that does is, if you
have two output variables
that you are maintaining
control charts for,
but they are functionally
interdependent,
you might not know
exactly how, but you
know that there's some
relationship between them.
A part that is out
of specification
may not trigger an
out of control alarm
on one of those control charts.
But if you plot both of
them together and look
at the results in
conjunction with one another,
that allows you to infer more
about whether the process is
in or out of control.
So it's covered in Montgomery.
We may have a problem
set question about it
as well to help you
develop understanding.
Anyway, I'm sorry.
I want to focus on ANOVA today.
Anyway, so we have the option of
looking at more than one input
and taking more than one
input value for each input.
And when we have different
levels for an input,
we're going to refer
to those as treatments.
So a variable may be treated
in one of a number of ways.
The outputs-- well, we're
dealing in this particular case
with one particular
quantity that we're
going to measure and analyze.
And we're going to have
two or more samples
that we are able to deal with.
So this is what
we're going to do.
We're going to look first for
the ANOVA technique applied
to one input variable.
And then, we're going to work
through an example of that.
Then we'll look at multivariable
analysis of variance
where you have--
in this particular
case, we're going
to look at two input
variables and how
we look at the interactions
of those two variables
in setting the output.
So here, we're going to start
with the single variable ANOVA.
And this is a diagram
that shows to you
what might happen to the output
of a process, which the output
being this axis as we vary one
particular input parameter.
So we're assuming we have
good control over this,
and we can command
that input parameter
to be whatever we choose.
In this particular case,
we're saying, well,
that there are three
possible values
we might be interested in--
A, B, and C. And so these
are the three treatments.
And what we've shown
here, schematically,
is the distribution of the
output variable under each
of those three conditions.
We're assuming
that the variation
in the output for each
particular treatment
is normally distributed, but
that the mean of the output
is determined directly by the
value of this input parameter.
So there's a one-to-one
deterministic relationship
between the mean and
the value of the input.
So these tau values--
tau 1, tau 2, and tau 3--
these are actually determined
directly by the populations.
But then, if we imagine
doing experiments
under these three conditions,
we're going to take--
we're going to set the input
to the value for sample A, say.
And then, we're going to take
a number of output parts,
measure them, and those
outputs will have--
they will have a
sample mean, y1.
And there will be, for each of
these samples, a sample mean.
We can take all
the data together
and come up with a grand
average for the collected data.
Then the differences between
those individual treatment
sample means and the grand
mean will be estimators
for the values of tau--
the effects of the treatments,
the different treatments
that we're doing.
So here's what we're doing.
We're considering
multiple settings
for some variable of interest.
And there are
these real effects,
deltas between the output
mean for different conditions.
And we've observed
these samples.
So the question is, based
on these observations,
we want to be able to
see whether the observed
differences in sample
means are real.
So we're going to do some kind
of hypothesis test that says,
the null hypothesis is
going to be changing
the input variable doesn't
make a blind bit of difference
to the output mean.
And the alternate
hypothesis is there
is a significant difference,
which, later, we want
to model somehow, probably.
What's important in
ANOVA is this assumption
that the variance of the
output for each treatment
is equivalent.
And here, we've written
it as sigma sub-0 squared.
So the width of each of
those subpopulations is--
has to be assumed to be equal.
And when one is
doing ANOVA, that's
something that one
needs to check.
And we'll talk about
that a little later.
Now, I'm going to describe
the underlying assumption that
allows the analysis of variance
to be done in this way.
And this underlying
assumption is
that you can model the
value of a sample part
as the sum of three quantities.
First quantity is
the process mean,
around which the
output means of all
the possible treatments center.
Second is the effect
of the treatment.
So that's how far is the
output mean of set when
you have this particular
treatment, tau, taking
place, whether there's a certain
voltage setting of the inputs,
or whatever.
And the third is
this residual term,
which we write with epsilon.
And that is describing the
random variation in the output
beyond the systematic
effect of the treatment.
Sometimes we take this mu
and the tau sub-t together.
We write it as a mu sub-t.
That's the output mean for
a particular treatment.
So at the bottom of this graph,
I've just sketched that out
to show what I mean.
Here is the process--
overall process mean.
Here is the output mean
for a particular treatment.
And say, if we take this
particular sample, for example,
then there's a residual.
There's a difference
between the treatment mean
and the actual value
of that sample, which
is epsilon sub-ti.
Sorry, that squared
shouldn't be there.
So the sum of these
three quantities
is thought of as giving
us the output quantity.
Now, I'm going to
describe the three steps
that one is going to
go through to test
this hypothesis that changing
the value of the input
has no effect on
the treatment means.
And the first step is to
come up with an estimate
of the underlying
population variance.
That involves looking at each
treatment sample in turn--
so looking at this
sample, then this sample,
and looking at the
sample variance
individually for
each sample, and then
taking a pooled estimate of the
random components of variation
based on all those
sample variances.
That's the first step.
Second step is to try to look
at the between group variation.
That means looking at
the sample means, which
I've denoted with
these horizontal lines
here, and looking at
the variance of those,
and making an inference from
that about how much variation
there is in the output as
we change the input setting.
Once we've got those
two estimates--
within group variation,
between group variation--
we want to compare
those estimates,
and infer from
that whether there
is a difference between
the different treatments.
If there is a
difference, then we're
going to expect
the second estimate
that we make to be larger
than the first estimate.
And just by looking
at this schematic
in the top right
of the view graph,
you can perhaps see
intuitively how that might be.
The variance associated with
the between group changes
is going to be larger if
there's a significant impact
of the input on the output.
But if not, then those
two variance estimates
should be equal.
There's no effect
had by the input.
I'm going to go through
each of those steps in turn,
and go through the mechanics
of how we're going to do that.
I've already said
that we're assuming
that the output for each
group-- and by group, I
mean the part sampled
for a given treatment,
so for a given setting
of the input variable--
we're saying that that
variation is described
by a variance of
sigma 0 squared,
and it's the same for each
group, which may be true
or may not be.
In which case, we need to
go back and think again.
So the second bullet
point here is giving us
sum of the squared deviations
for the teeth group.
And so this is just saying,
we have a sample value
for the output-- y sub-ti.
We've taken a mean for the
group, y bar sub-t, which
is here, and we're
summing the squares
of the deviations between these
values and the sample mean.
Once we've done that,
it's a simple step
to go to the group variance.
So this is an unbiased
estimate of the group variance.
The sum of the square is
divided by the number of degrees
of freedom in that treatment.
So that's the number of
parts sampled minus 1.
And the minus 1 is because,
well, the value of the mean--
y bar sub-t, is dependent on
all the individual y sub-ti's.
So there's one less
degree of freedom
than there are data points.
Once we've got each of
those group variances
based on the data,
we're going to take
a pool estimate of the
common within group variance.
So inherent in this,
again, is the assumption
that the variance
could be modeled
as being equal for each group.
And actually, that
should be a sub-2.
But what we're doing,
this is effectively
taking a weighted average based
on the number of data points
that we have for each group.
So we might take more samples
for a particular treatment,
but we can deal
with that by using
the correct number of degrees
of freedom for each treatment.
And what we get out of that
is this pooled estimate
of [INAUDIBLE] variance
s sub-r squared.
So that was the
within group variance.
And now, we're going to
talk about the between group
variance.
As I said, we're
testing the hypothesis
that varying the input does not
cause the output mean to vary.
If that were true,
then what I've
sketched on the bottom left
here would be the case.
You would have three
populations that
looked absolutely identical.
And it wouldn't matter what
value you chose for the input.
You'd get the same output.
However, when you sample,
we know that, of course,
because there's random
variation in the output,
the sample mean will
not always be the same.
And that will vary.
The sample mean will, itself,
be normally distributed
with a variance of
sigma 0 squared over n,
where n is the number
of samples in--
the number of data
points in the sample.
So this is looking
a little bit--
on the bottom right-- a little
bit like a control chart,
where the y-axis
is could be thought
of as being linked to sigma 0
squared divided by the sample
size.
And so what this all means
is that if the hypothesis was
true-- inputs don't
affect the output mean--
then we could form
a second estimate
of the within group variation
by looking at it this way, where
we are taking the
treatment mean, which
are these values here.
We're subtracting the
grand mean of all the data
from each treatment
mean in turn.
We're taking the square
of those deviations.
And this n sub-t here
is counting for the fact
that, because of the
central limit theorem,
the variance of the sample
mean is inversely proportional
to the sample size, and k is the
number of different treatments.
So in this case, k is 3.
So we're making this
estimate, s sub-t squared,
which, in the case
I've sketched here,
we would expect to be
equal to s sub-r squared.
However, if that isn't
the case, if there
is a significant relationship
between the input
and the output,
then s sub-t squared
will be larger than
s sub-r squared.
And that's the quantity
by which it's larger--
this sum here.
And this value, tau sub-t,
is the real difference--
the actual systematic
change in output
mean that occurs when
we vary the input.
So we're causing an inflation
in the value of s sub-t squared
based on the fact that
changing the input
changes the output mean.
So we've got these
two estimates--
that within group variation and
the between group variation.
We want to look at them,
and compare them, and say,
is there a significant
impact on the output
when we go through these
different treatments?
So we're comparing
two variances.
And that means that what
we're interested in doing
is an F test.
So we're asking
ourselves, how big
is the chance that, if the
null hypothesis were true,
we would observe
these two variances?
We're going to make
the test statistic
the ratio s sub-t squared
divided by s sub-r squared.
So that's going to usually
be a value greater than 1.
And we reject the null
hypothesis if that value is
significantly greater than 1.
What it's worth
remembering here--
go ahead.
AUDIENCE: When you
say significantly,
you mean factor of
ten, factor of--
PROFESSOR: Well,
we're going to do an F
test at a chosen level of
significance to work that out.
And that's exactly what this
slide says, so good question.
We have this F statistic.
And we're now going
to interpret that.
We're going to pick a particular
significance level, which
we want to say, is it--
at the 5% level,
is it significant
that there's a relationship
between the treatment that's
chosen and the output mean?
It's important to remember
that this is a one-sided F test
that we're interested in doing.
The possibility
we're considering
is that sigma sub-t
squared is greater
than sigma sub-r squared.
The case where the real
value between group variance
is less than the real value
of the within group variance
is not something that
has a physical meaning.
So it's a one-sided F test where
the statistic we're expecting
to be bigger than 1--
much bigger than 1.
And here are the
degrees of freedom
that we need to use
for that evaluation.
And that's, based on what
we've learned so far, fairly
straightforward test to do.
We can also make this
additional estimate,
which is based on the sum
of the squared deviations
from the grand mean
among all samples.
And that can be useful
in a number of ways,
although it's not central to
evaluating this F statistic
and testing the hypothesis
that we've described.
This slide is pretty important.
So this shows you how
one usually would lay out
an ANOVA analysis.
And we would put real
quantities in the spaces
shown by expressions here.
We'd evaluate the
sum of the squares
between treatments
and within treatments.
And we'd figure out what the
number of degrees of freedom
was.
We'd look at the estimates
of our variances,
we'd take their ratio,
and we would then
use F tables to find the
probability that, by chance,
that value of f
sub-0 was observed
if the null hypothesis of 0
treatment effects were true.
And it's worth remembering
this word "residual."
So before, when I highlighted
that quantity epsilon, which
is the variation associated
with randomness, the thing
that we're not trying
to model in looking
at these different
treatments, that
is accounted for by this sum
of squares within treatments.
What I'm going to do now is work
through a very simple example
to show how this single
variable ANOVA can be done.
And it will hopefully give
you a feel for the steps that
have to be gone through.
This sort of thing is automated
in a number of programs.
There are macros available
in Excel to do it.
But it's worth knowing exactly
what the steps are so that you
understand what's going on.
What we've got here
are three samples
for each of three treatments
of a particular variable.
So this is the output that
we've measured in some arbitrary
quantity.
And here are the treatments.
So for each
particular treatment,
we have three samples.
We evaluate a sample mean.
Here, it's 11.
Here it's 8.
And we take the grand
average of all samples,
and we know that as well.
We can also evaluate the
sum of squared deviations
of the sample values
from the sample mean.
And in this case, sum of
squares for treatment one
is the square of
that difference,
plus the square that
difference, plus 0,
because that particular
sample lies on the mean.
We do that for each
particular treatment,
and evaluate these
sums of squares.
We know that there are
two degrees of freedom
for each particular sample.
So we can go
straight to estimates
of the within group variances
for each group or treatment.
And based on that, we can
evaluate that pool estimate
of within group
variance, which is
the thing that's
meant to be excluding
the effect of the treatments.
Now what we're going to do
is make the second estimate--
the between group
variance estimate.
And here, what we're doing
is looking purely at--
we're interested
purely in the sample
means that we've evaluated.
Take this value, this
value, and this value.
That sample mean is 11.
The grand average for
all samples is 10.
We're looking at
that difference,
and we're squaring
that deviation here,
and then we're scaling it
by the number of samples
for that particular
treatment, which is 3--
3 samples.
And that's, again,
dealing with the fact
that the standard
deviation of a sample mean
is inversely proportional
to the number of data
points in the sample.
So we do this for each
treatment-- t equals 1, 2,
and 3--
and we evaluate our estimate
of the between group variance.
So this estimate, in a
sense, is trying to look--
well, folded into
that estimate will
be the effect of the random
variation within the group
and the effect of
changing the treatment.
We have these two estimates--
sigma sub-r squared,
sigma sub-t squared.
Now, we're going
to do the F test
to see whether there's
a significant evidence
that changing the input
changes the output.
Here's how we might
lay it out in Excel.
We've evaluated the sums
of squares between groups
within square--
within groups, sorry.
We've got the degrees
of freedom here.
The mean squared value is
just taken from over here.
And the F statistic is just the
between group estimate divided
by the within group
estimate, so 4 1/2.
And then we can go to
the tables and say,
the 5% level, what's
the critical value of f?
It turns out to be 5.14.
So in this case, we would--
the 5% level rejects--
accept the null hypothesis that
there was no significant effect
of inputs on outputs.
AUDIENCE: Is the ratio
always larger than 1?
How can it be smaller--
PROFESSOR: There's a chance
that it will be smaller
than 1, even if the
actual output means were
unaffected by the input.
But again, that would be--
so if this is the value
of f and this is the PDF--
I forget.
This would be what the f
distribution looks like.
So there are values of f that
are less than 1 down here.
But the 5% level, you would only
reject the hypothesis that--
so f crit here is
5.14, the 5% level.
You would reject the
hypothesis that there
was no significant impact of
inputs on outputs if you--
this particular variable input,
obviously-- if the value of f
were greater than that.
So yeah, there's a small chance
that f will be less than 1.
I think that's right.
Is that right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, certainly.
If the observed
f is less than 1,
that would for sure tell you
that the treatments are not
having an effect.
It means your treatment deltas
are so small that in fact, you
got lucky, your sample with 0
treatment effects in that case
was of course even
smaller variance than the
in group variance, which
happened purely by chance.
So if you actually
observed an f less than 1,
exactly as Hayden
said, you would reject
the alternative hypothesis.
You'd just have to say,
yeah, there's no effect.
PROFESSOR: OK, well, that
is the whole example.
That's what you would do if
you had nine data points,
and you could write it
down on one bit of paper.
Obviously, not everything
is that simple.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: OK, go back
to previous slide.
So the p value mean says if
the r is larger than 0.064,
we will reject the
null hypothesis, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the p value
is the level of significance
at which you would just
reject the null hypothesis.
So that's the level
of significance
for which f is equal to f crit.
And in this case, it's 6.4%.
So if the level of
significance is 5%,
that's a more stringent--
places a more
stringent requirement
to reject the null
hypothesis than than 6.4%.
So you would keep the null
hypothesis at the 5% level.
AUDIENCE: So in fact,
this is a good example
where, if I asked you just
directly the question,
did the treatment
have an effect,
your answer is dependent
on what level of confidence
you wanted [INAUDIBLE]
of the evidence
tells you there was an effect.
If I asked you, I want to be 95%
confident there was an effect,
your answer would be I
don't have enough evidence.
No, there's no effect.
If I asked you instead,
90% confident that there's
an effect, your
answer is yes, there
is an effect to 90% confidence.
So you're right at
that interesting point
with that 6.4--
what is it?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, 6.4.
AUDIENCE: 6.4%.
And if you just look at
the scatter of the data,
it's kind of fuzzy.
You don't have a lot of data.
You only have three data
points in each sample.
So that whole idea of confidence
interval we talked about early
in the term.
It's very important.
PROFESSOR: OK, any more
questions from anyone?
Right.
Well, we mentioned at the
start that inherent in doing
this analysis is the assumption
that the within group variance
is the same for every group.
And that this actually
should be a sigma, not a 3/4.
It's important to
check that to make sure
that the ANOVA is valid.
And there are ways of
looking at the problem
differently if you can't
really make that assumption.
But what we also
want to do is try
to make sure that the
analysis we're doing really
does capture as much as possible
of the treatment effect.
And there are various
ways of doing that.
We can take the
residuals-- in other words,
the difference between the
sample value and the sample
mean.
We can plot those
residuals either
against the time order in
which the samples were taken.
We could look at
the distribution
of those residuals,
do a QQnorm plot
or some other kind of plot.
And we can make checks that
this underlying assumption
is reasonable.
So that's all I'm going
to say about this.
But I think it's an important
thing to bear in mind.
So ANOVA for one
variable, though it
takes quite a lot of effort
to get it conceptually,
the actual mechanics of doing
it are fairly straightforward.
It's not always the case that
there's only one input variable
that we're interested
in changing.
We might, of course, want to
do it with two or more input
variables.
There are good
reasons why we'd be
interested in exploiting
a number of inputs
to achieve the output we want.
If we have several
variables we can control,
we can do things
like controlling
the output mean and
the output variance
to be what we want them to be.
Or we can control the
output to improve CPK,
while at the same time
reducing sensitivity
to some other disturbance.
And that is why we need to be
able to do analysis of variance
for multiple inputs.
One way of modeling the effect
of these multiple inputs
would be to have this
simple additive model, where
we are saying that
the output value is
the sum of four quantities--
process mean, as we
mentioned before, and then
two separate treatment
effects, tau sub-t
as we described for the
one variable case, and then
an equivalent value for
another input, beta sub-q.
And in this case, we
would say that there
were there were k possible
treatments at first variable,
and n possible treatments
for the second.
So you could have any
one of the treatments
for the first
variable, with any one
of the treatments for the
second variable in combination.
The fourth quantity is, again,
this residual-- this random
variation that's
not something we're
trying to account for with
these two input variables.
And again, this is what we
call a fixed effects model.
So we're saying that there's
a deterministic relationship
between the input values and
the value of tau sub-t and beta
sub-q.
There are cases in which there's
a probabilistic relationship
between the input and
those treatment effects.
There are ways of
dealing with that
that we won't describe here.
The model that is up on the
board now is pretty simple.
It assumes that the effects of
these two inputs are additive.
There are plenty of cases,
plenty of processes where
that simply isn't realistic.
And there's some synergism
between the two inputs.
An example that I
can think of that's
been be relevant
in my research is
in modeling the etching rate
in a silicon plasma etching
chamber, where there are--
I guess you could think of
it as there being two really
important input
quantities, which
are the flux of ions of reactant
onto the surface of the wafer,
the flux of uncharged
fluorine radicals, which
are the chemical species that
are responsible for chemical
etching of the circuit.
So you have these two
fluxes approaching
the surface of the wafer.
And it's not just the case that
the rate of removal of silicon
is proportional to some weighted
sum of those two fluxes.
You can't really have
etching unless you
have a substantial flux of
both ions and these fluorine
neutrals, so that the
ions provide the energy
for the reaction to occur.
And that means that the
model I just described
wouldn't get us very far.
We need to be able to
deal with an interaction
between those two inputs.
This is how we can represent it.
We can add in a
fifth term, which
is specific to the combination
of treatments t and q.
Let's look at how we might
incorporate that into ANOVA.
Here, we look at the
within group variance
for a particular--
for particular input variable.
So this is for the
first input variable.
The treatment is tau.
And then, we have the
equivalent expression
for what happens with
the second variable.
Then, we have this
interaction term,
which is an estimate of the
variance that's to do with--
that can't be explained
by this additive idea,
and finally, the residuals-- so
taking the actual value of the
of the outputs minus the grand
mean, squaring those residuals.
And what this leads us to
is a two-way way ANOVA table
where we can evaluate
3 F statistics,
and apply 3 F tests to look
for significant relationships
between factor 1 and the
output, factor 2 and the output,
and for a significant amount of
interaction between those two
factors in setting the output.
Katerina, you had a question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
or whether [INAUDIBLE]
graphic you were
showing us earlier,
with a [INAUDIBLE] Would
this be between groups,
or is it within one?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, this is--
sorry, this is between
groups, isn't it?
AUDIENCE: Could you
repeat the question?
PROFESSOR: Oh, right.
Yes, Katerina was asking,
are these estimates
within group estimates or
between group estimates?
And yes, absolutely,
you're right.
These are actually
between group estimates.
So we're taking a sample mean
and looking at its deviation
from the grand
mean for all data.
And we're making an
estimate, based on that,
of the between group mean.
So this is folding into it
some of the effect of varying
the input.
Question in Singapore?
AUDIENCE: Yes, for si
squared, shouldn't it
be ytq minus yt, minus yq,
plus y instead of minus y,
according to a slide you
showed just before this slide?
PROFESSOR: Did I show--
oh, yeah, OK.
Yes, I'm sorry.
That's a mistake.
Yeah, you're quite right.
Thank you very much.
Absolutely.
Anyway, we have these estimates
of the between group variances
and the interaction variance.
And we have these
three F statistics
that we can use separately to
test separate null hypotheses
that there's no
impact to factor 1
on the output, no input
of factor 2 on the output,
and get to test the
hypothesis that there's
no importance in any interaction
between those factors.
So now, I want to give an
example of where this analysis
could be relevant and useful.
Now, we often think about the
relationship between inputs
and outputs being
described where
we're varying some
inputs over time,
and the output is
changing over time.
The output mean could
be shifting over time.
So we have a machine,
and we're trying
different settings for it.
But in fact, a lot of cases in
semiconductor process control,
we're interested in
spatial variations.
And you can think of the
case I'm going to show you.
This is for a metal etching
process where we're--
some work that we've started
with one of our collaborators.
The idea is that we want
to be able to model.
And we're etching a metal layer
to form interconnect wires
to be able to model how
uniformly that etches
across a wafer, depending on
how densely the features are
packed, what their
individual sizes are,
and where they're
situated on the wafer.
One problem that
you can encounter
when processing these metal
layers is that the metal,
you're masking a blanket layer
of the metal with photoresist,
and then applying a
plasma to the wafer
to etch the exposed metal away.
But as that process
happens, you can
you can get sideways
etching of the metal.
And imagine you have
a photoresist layer.
This is a cross-section
I'm sketching here.
And you're etching a
trench into the metal
down to some insulating layer.
Agents have to enter this gap.
Depending on the
size of the gap,
that transport
process will vary.
It will be harder
in narrower gaps
than in wider gaps for
the reaction to get in,
for the products to get out.
But also, there's going
to be some lateral etching
of the metal.
And the rate at which that
lateral etching happens
will depend on the
availability of reactants
in the region of
that feature, which
might vary across the wafer.
If there is this lateral
etching, if it varies,
then it's going to
affect the final width
of the wire, its final
resistance, and therefore
the speed at which an
individual capacitor,
parasitic or otherwise, in
the circuit will charge.
So you might find that if
you can't reduce variation
in this lateral etching
process, the circuit properties
of the devices produced
will vary substantially
across the wafer.
So there are several
things that can
affect the availability of
reactants at a given feature.
Firstly, there is the
position in the chamber.
And what I've sketched
in the top left
is a plan view of a wafer.
This is, say, maybe one
of several wafers sitting
in a large plasma
etching chamber.
The gases flow through this
chamber with some path,
some velocity distribution.
The design of the
chamber will have
an impact on the
density of reactants
and how it varies
across the wafer.
So you might find that
there's greater availability
of reactants at the
center of the wafer.
That's because there's an
inlet above the center.
And so that's one thing
that can affect the amount
of lateral metal etching.
Then, you have the
actual geometry
of the pattern that
is being etched.
If you're trying to etch
a large amount of metal
in a given region
of the wafer, that
will act as a sink
for reactants.
There will be a
lot of competition
for these reactants.
The concentration
locally at the surface
is likely to be depressed.
And that's going to reduce
the lateral etching rate
for any individual feature.
So we have this what we're
going to call pattern density
effect--
density of exposed
metal for etching.
Finally, the thing that
can affect the availability
of reactants for
this lateral etching
is the size of the
feature, as I mentioned.
Narrower features provide
a greater impediment
to the transport of reactants
to the side wall of the feature.
So in a way, you could
think of these phenomena
as being input variables.
Some of them you can control.
If you wanted to, you
could place constraints
on what kind of
density of features
were available, what the
smallest feature available was
to the designer, these chips.
And to an extent,
you can control
the tool-related variation.
You can choose a
process that will
give a more uniform distribution
of gases in the chamber.
You could redesign the chamber.
And some of that variation
you don't have an easy way
to control.
Some of that-- you don't have
complete control over all
the inputs.
But what I'm saying
is that this is
a case where you have
multiple geometrical input
variations where you're
trying to manufacture
many identical chips.
Each square in this
graph is one chip.
And they're all supposed to
be identical to one another.
But because of the effects
I described they will not,
in fact, be identical.
So you can think
of this as being--
a wafer as being many
interdependent samples
of the output of a process
where the input is varying
in, in some cases,
an uncontrolled way,
in some cases a way
you can control.
So this would be a really meaty
problem for multivariate ANOVA
to deal with.
What we've got
within each chip--
this is actually
a test chip that
was designed to do some
experiments and build a model.
So it's not actually a product.
But within each
chip, what we have
is many copies of actually
the same sorts of features.
In fact, what they are is
just snake-shaped wires
which have a total length
that amplifies any resistance
variations caused by
the lateral etching.
You can go into the
chip and you can probe
the resistance of these wires.
As the lateral
etching gets faster,
the resistance gets higher,
because the wires are narrower.
So you have many of
these snake features
within each of these
individual squares.
And what we do is we surrounded
those the same features
by a different amount of
padding metal, which is not
electrically connected
to these snakes
but is sitting right next
to the snake structures,
so that they're perturbing
the transport of etching gas.
So in areas where there's a
larger amount of metal exposed
for etching, there's going
to be greater competition
for reactants
locally, and there's
going to be a lower etch rate,
including a lower lateral etch
rate.
It's not necessarily
true, of course,
that the pattern density
effects are confined
to one of these squares.
You may find that the lengths
over which competition
for reactants occur are larger
than the diameter of one
of these patches.
And that is something
that would need
to be modeled and dealt with
in understanding the process.
So I'm not going to go through
the analysis of variance
for this problem.
I just wanted to
highlight the fact
that there are these complicated
sets of geometrical input
variables that we want to
try to understand often
in semiconductor
manufacturing processes.
And very often,
we want to just go
beyond finding a
functional relationship
between some
geometrical property
and the performance
of the products.
We want to build a physical
model that will work as far
back as the settings on
the machine, the flow
rates of gases, the
amount of electrical power
that's going into generating
the plasma in the chamber,
to try to work back
with enough detail
that we can start to decide
what good input variable
values would be.
I'm just going to show
you a little bit of data
from one of these test wafers.
You can see that we've
identified a clear relationship
between the pattern density--
the amount of padding metal
within one of those sets
of features-- and the
average resistance
of one of the snakes.
There are several hundred
snakes within each given
patch of features.
And what we've done here is
just average the resistance
of all of them to
give a quick estimate
of the effect of local pattern
density and input variable
on one important output.
So we can see that the
pattern density has
an effect that we could
think of inventing
a functional model for.
But what we also have is the
wafer scale non-uniformity.
This is to do with the way
gases flow around the chamber,
approach the wafer, are
transported across the wafer.
And this graph shows you a
subset of the data we have.
Down in the bottom left
is a diagram of the wafer.
And what we've
done on this graph
is plotted the resistance
of a particular test
feature, a resistive snake,
within each chip on the wafer
as a function of location.
We slice up the wafer.
And the x-axis corresponds to
each slice of the wafer being
concatenated.
The first slice is
here, the second slice
is here, and so forth.
What we see is that the
resistances that result
tend to be larger in
the center of the wafer.
Here's a central part of the
wafer, and here is an edge.
So that relationship is clear.
But then, if we look
within each chip,
if we look at the features that
are near this 5% local metal
density, then we see
this amount of variation.
And if we look in
the region where
there's a much higher
amount of metal density,
therefore less of the
metal is being etched away,
we see that the resistance
is higher, and--
I'm sorry, by pattern
density we mean
the proportion of the chip
that is open for etching.
And we see that the
resistance is higher
because there's more there's
more lateral etching.
But what this gives
us an indication of
is that there must
be an interaction.
Because the size of the
wafer scale non-uniformity
depends on the local
pattern density.
It's not as if we're taking
the 5% variation pattern
and we're shifting it up.
When we change to
85% pattern density,
there is a change in the shape
of the location dependence
as we change the
local pattern density.
And that is an example of one
of those interaction effects
that we would need
to capture, so
either through some
multiplicative model
or something more
physically-based.
Anyway, that is the
end of today's lecture.
Next time, we're going to
use these techniques, ANOVA,
as the basis for starting to
build real models where we're
actually fleshing
out the functional
relationship between
inputs and outputs,
and designing experiments
that will give us
that information as
efficiently as possible.
OK, are there any
questions from either side?
Hello.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
have one question.
As for the ANOVA,
you have, like,
three parameters-- a
k, n, and m, right?
So does m always control
n multiplied by k?
PROFESSOR: Actually,
yeah, m in that
case was the number of samples
per combination of treatment.
So actually, in MANOVA, the
quantity that I termed m
is a bit like n in the
single variable ANOVA.
I know that's confusing.
But here, m the
number of replicates
for a given combination of
input variables t and q.
Does that make sense?
So we have a combination
of inputs t and q.
We keep them constant.
We sample a few parts for
that combination of inputs.
And there are m of those parts.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Thanks.
Anyone else?
OK, well, thank you.
The problem is due on Thursday.
Let me know if you have
any questions about it.
I'm sure you will.
Oh, hello?
AUDIENCE: Can I
check in with you?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
AUDIENCE: For the quiz, I'm
not sure which question.
I think it probably be the
last section of problem 1.
I think I needed a [INAUDIBLE]
table with r for equal
to 0.025, but we were
not provided with that.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure
whether I'm wrong, or--
PROFESSOR: About ten
people asked me at this end
about that.
Well, you know, I actually
think that a one-sided F
test would have been
appropriate in that case.
In which case, the table--
the 0.05 table would have
been appropriate to do
a one-sided 5% F test.
It was also possible
to answer that question
by looking at the confidence
intervals from part B
and seeing whether
they overlapped.
And I think they didn't
overlap, did they?
So they didn't overlap.
So we said there was a
significant difference.
But anyway we'll
publish solutions.
Thanks, anyone else?
No?
Good.
AUDIENCE: One question.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
PROFESSOR: That's OK.
AUDIENCE: For the
MANOVA, there--
OK, for ANOVA
there's a term that
is the 0 mean normal residual.
And for MANOVA,
there's the same term.
But in the second line,
the term disappeared.
Do you know what I'm talking
about-- on previous slide?
PROFESSOR: On the
previous-- this slide?
This slide?
AUDIENCE: No, previous,
previous slide--
two slides ago.
Oh, yeah, this one.
PROFESSOR: This one.
AUDIENCE: The term
disappears later.
The last term on the--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, oh,
you mean the term--
there's a term here, but
there isn't a term here.
Is that what you mean?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Ah, right, well, the
second line is an estimate
of the value of the output for
the combination of inputs t
and q.
An estimate is not trying to
make any predictions about what
was a residual will be.
It's really dealing just with
means for a given treatment.
And it's saying, if, say, you
set your machine to input 1
having value t, input
2 having value q,
what's your best estimate
of what the output will be?
And that estimate has
to be the mean output.
There's no point making
anything other than a mean.
And so the residual,
that epsilon term,
is present in real
data, because there's
random variation in the output
around the expected mean.
AUDIENCE: Another way to say
that is your best estimate
of epsilon [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you
could put, like, a--
you could put a plus 0 there
if that's your best guess.
PROFESSOR: OK, did you
hear that in Singapore?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, good.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PROFESSOR: Anyone else?
OK, see you next time.